So today we've talked about classification, which is one of the biggest
problems in AI. We started by revisiting incremental concept learning and
reminding ourselves how it allowed us to take examples and
abstract away a concept. We then looked at the idea of equivalence classes and
how we can group sets of percepts into equivalence classes to establish
a particular instance of a concept. Within this is the hierarchies of concepts,
such as the animal kingdom,
where animals can grow kind of into vertebrae, birds and penguins.
We then discuss the idea of different types of concepts like axiomatic or
exemplar concepts, and how each of them have different definitions and different
affordances. Finally, we discuss bottom-up search, so instead of establish and
refine, we look at the lower level variables and abstract up from them. Next,
we're going to move on to logic, which is a little bit unrelated to this.
But if you're interested in classification, you can look ahead to all our
different lessons on design, such as diagnosis and configuration.
They're going to really heavily leverage our idea of classification.